cuantos de los que estáis aquí veis
contenido netflix podéis levantar la
mano
bueno pero todos los que habéis
levantado la mano y también los que no
conocéis bien la marca no pero tal vez
no seáis muy conscientes de su magnitud
esto es netflix decís es una
multinacional que tiene más de 139
millones de suscriptores y que está
presente en más de 190 países todos los
que en este mapa están pintados de rojo
y si esta cifra no ha hecho que abráis
los ojos seguro que está que os voy a
dar ahora lo hará y es que el 15 por
ciento del tráfico que tiene lugar en
internet en todo el mundo es tráfico de
netflix y si alguno se lo pregunta el
segundo es youtube con un 11 por ciento
y si se puede ser más o menos fan de
netflix pero lo cierto es que todos
reconoceréis conmigo que es una empresa
que ha cambiado profundamente las reglas
del juego y que aparte su ascenso ha
sido meteórico en el año 2000
netflix lanzaba una oferta de compra por
una popular cadena de videoclubs que
probablemente sueños o colas de
blockbuster
bueno pues blockbuster por aquel
entonces más o menos que se rió en su
cara y diez años después cuando en el
flash ya valía dos mil millones de
dólares
blockbuster se declarará en bancarrota
a día de hoy netflix vale 150 mil
millones de dólares y roma- una de sus
producciones originales ha sido la
película más nominada en los oscar de
2019 y estos son sólo unos ejemplos para
que nos demos cuenta de cuál es la
magnitud y el impacto económico que ha
tenido netflix tanto en las cifras de
hollywood como la propia industria del
entretenimiento
no os asustéis que yo no sé venir a
hablar de la economía ni de las finanzas
de netflix os vengo aquí a hablar de una
cosa que os afecta muchísimo más que es
como netflix nos está influyendo y no se
está transformando a nosotros
netflix lleva en nuestro país desde 2015
en apenas cuatro años pensando bien se
ha colado en nuestras teles en nuestros
móviles en nuestros viajes al trabajo en
nuestras conversaciones probablemente
nos habrá robado alguna que otra hora
del sueño
verdad
hemos cancelado planes por culpa de
netflix admitirlo
y probablemente se habrá provocado
alguna que otra sencilla
con vuestra pareja porque al parecer el
tema de las infidelidades sería filas es
una cosa muy importante que está
arrastrando más a la gente a las
consultas del psicólogo rezando bien que
netflix al final se ha hecho un hueco en
nuestras vidas en un tiempo
absolutamente recorrió es garantizo que
para mí que yo era una niña en los 80
eso me convierte pues en esta generación
tan bolón a gracias a stranger things a
mí lo de netflix os garantizo que me
parece absoluta ciencia ficción y ahora
voy a poner en contexto cuando yo era
pequeña si tú querías ver una peli una
serie en tu casa lo tenías que hacer en
la tele y la tele era una cosa grande y
cuadrada que estaba en el salón
y lo tenía que compartir con todos los
miembros de la familia imaginaos lo que
se suponía si como en mi caso erase
varios hermanos
porque para decidir que se veía había
que ponerse de acuerdo bueno en mi caso
esto era súper fácil porque al final
sabía lo que decía mi padre
yo veo alguna cara de incredulidad entre
los nativos digitales de la sala veo que
hay muchos
pero os aseguro que esto es así extras y
esto no es el upside world y de hecho
para los que no visteis la esta etapa
analógica de la televisión
la cosa os garantizo que se va a poner
bastante más terrorífica porque además
de tener una única tele o dos si eras
muy afortunado aquí durante mucho tiempo
sólo había dos cadenas
y las cosas había que verlas el día que
se emitían y a la hora a la que se
emitían y con unos bloques eternos de
publicidad
y si luego la cosa mejoró luego
empezamos a tener más libertad a mi casa
llegó el vhs aparecieron las tiendas de
alquiler de videos aparecieron las
cadenas comerciales las mamachicho
antena3
la televisión de pago con más canales
aquellos cajeros en los que alquilaba
los acordes los cajeros en los que se
alquilaban dvds luego néstor en mega
vídeo pero realmente el cambio profundo
el cambio estructural para mí llegó con
netflix para mí con netflix
para mí fue como si hubiesen puesto en
mis manos las llaves de una inmensa
mansión llena de contenido me hubiesen
dicho toma tienes total libertad para
ver todo el contenido que quieras como
cuánto y donde quieras y aparte por un
precio que me parecía bastante asequible
por todas las ventajas que me estaban
ofreciendo qué ventajas vayamos a
inventariar las pues no tener que ver el
contenido única y exclusivamente en la
tele lo podía ver en más pantallas
una oferta amplia mejor o peor pero más
amplia e inmediata
el hecho de no tener que ver una cosa un
día y una hora concreto es lo cual para
mí era mentalmente un alivio en no tener
que vivir pendiente de programas
grabaciones o de acostarme super tarde
porque quería ver un programa en directo
y sobre todo
el no tener que esperar una semana para
ver el siguiente capítulo de mi serie
favorita ellos yo marco mi vida un antes
y un después es netflix marcó el punto
de inflexión en el que yo dejé de tener
vida social
y empecé a ver una cantidad
absolutamente obscena de capítulos de
una sentada ahora genial no
lo que ocurre es que
creo que no somos demasiado conscientes
del peaje que estamos pagando por todo
esto porque si nos han puesto en las
manos una mansión llena de contenido
pero en cierta medida a costa de
volvernos sus prisioneros porque esta
aparente libertad que tenemos para
elegir no es tan real como nosotros
creemos
lo primero que tenéis que entender es
que para netflix los clientes son la
base de su negocio
netflix gana dinero con cada persona que
se da de alta y lo pierde con cada
persona que se da de baja de manera que
para netflix el éxito consiste en captar
nuevos suscriptores y retener a los que
ya tiene y como lo consigue con una
fuerza misteriosa y poderosa está súper
de moda ahora es probable que hayáis
oído hablar de ella que se llama
engagement
toda la vida le hemos llamado
fidelización
tener al cliente contento
y cuál es el cliente contento de netflix
pues aquel que entra de algo se lo pasa
bien se va y luego vuelve
netflix está específicamente diseñado
para que paséis el mayor número de horas
conectados posibles porque porque cuanto
más tiempo estés conectado a netflix
viendo cosas que te gustan y cuantas más
recurrentes sean tus visitas menor
probabilidad habrá de que te des de baja
y por qué digo que tú no decides lo que
es en netflix
por una razón muy sencilla porque
netflix cree que lo puedo hacer mejor
que tú
o al menos cree que lo puedo hacer de
una manera más eficiente
de alguna manera en el fin no se fía de
que nosotros seamos capaces de gestionar
todo este catálogo que nos ponen delante
y lo cierto es que no les faltan motivos
para esta preocupación porque si el
contenido es inmediato pero eso no
significa que nuestras decisiones lo
sean
de hecho la neurociencia nos dice que
cuanto más grande es la oferta que
nosotros tenemos delante de nosotros más
difíciles son nuestras elecciones
y ahora y después hace una cosa todos
hemos vivido este momento llevas días
viendo tu serie favorita y de repente
termina
crisis pánico consultas a tus amigos que
sé que me recomiendas y de repente te
lanzas al vacío de entrar en netflix y
te pones a navegar desesperado a ver si
encuentras algo
que te guste
y al poco tiempo ya estás navegando sin
rumbo dando tumbos scroll e ando todo lo
que ves te parece mediocre y ya llega un
momento que esto sí ya sé que voy a
acabar pasando de netflix y moviera a
ver historias de instagram
verdad que sí si os suena que es lo que
ha pasado
tu cerebro se ha bloqueado
completamente en este libro sabe hecho
netflix sabe el tiempo que tardas en
entrar en este bucle de indecisión 90
segundos
el tiempo que se para un usuario que no
sabe qué ver entra y encuentra algo del
que se va de la aplicación completamente
frustrado es un minuto y medio
un minuto y medio
así que netflix dice vale tengo de un
lado un montón de contenido diverso de
otro lado tengo un montón de usuarios
más de 139 millones igualmente diversos
y con unas preferencias muy diversas y
aparte perezosos y con poca paciencia
entonces lo que yo intento o lo que voy
a intentar cada vez que un cliente le da
entra en netflix y suena el turn es
conseguir emparejarlo con un contenido
que sea afín a sus preferencias esto
suena
suena esta mecánica
pues hace entender
vale sabes lo que está intentando es
emparejar nos con el contenido y que
necesita netflix para que se produzca
este match pues necesita dos cosas
conocer muy bien al usuario y conocer
muy bien al contenido y cuando digo lo
de conocer muy bien el contenido igual
me ha quedado corta porque más que
conocerlo neces lo que hace es
diseccionar lo netflix tiene un
ingrediente secreto que son unas
personas a las que paga por ver series y
películas nos está engañando esto es un
trabajo real se les llama taggers y son
profesionales a los que enseñan a ver
contenido para que sean capaces de
inventariar aquellos aspectos que les
permitan conocer muy bien cada contenido
para poder relacionarlo con otros
contenidos y a su vez conectarlo con los
usuarios
qué tipo de elementos indexan pues por
ejemplo si una película tiene un final
feliz
transcurre la segunda guerra mundial
si te puede ayudar a olvidar a tu ex
pareja si salen animales si sale en
familias disfuncionales
y porque esto es útil pues nos lo voy a
explicar con un ejemplo nosotros
imaginaos ahora un universo en el que
jamás hubiese oído hablar de house of
cards sé que es un poco difícil parece
ser esfuerzo
ahora imaginaros cuando no es fácil de
producir house of cards la coloca en su
catálogo
siguiendo una definición básica de
géneros y lo coloca bajo una categoría
que se llame dramas políticos
o sea que los dramas políticos que dan
una pereza espantosa lo más probable es
que jamás te animes a ver house of cards
pero si a ti te gustan las ficciones
protagonizadas por mujeres empoderadas y
te colocan lo colocan debajo de una
categoría que pon que se diga
series galardonadas con un sólido
personaje femenino
tu percepción del contenido cambia
automáticamente y esta es la base de una
arquitectura de géneros absolutamente
insólita porque lo normal es que
nosotros clasificamos los géneros en
base a categorías básicas como por
ejemplo thriller drama comedia pero en
netflix existen hasta 75.000 micro
géneros de estas características y de
hecho netflix gracias a sus algoritmos
en la magia de los algoritmos se está
colocando constantemente el contenido en
diferentes categorías para ver en cuál
de ellas se logra convencer
y todavía tienen un as en la manga
porque un proceso muy similar al que
utilizan con estas etiquetas de
contenido lo siguen lo utilizan con las
imágenes ellos pagan a personas para que
seleccionen imágenes relevantes y
escenas relevantes del contenido porque
nunca veréis en netflix un póster o una
carátula de un dvd ellos están
seleccionando imágenes y escenas y luego
la magia de los algoritmos te presenta
el contenido con diferentes apariencias
que consiguen con esto llegar a públicos
muy diversos porque probablemente a una
persona le anime a hacer clic en un
contenido
el hecho de ver un actor que vio en la
casa de papel y a otra persona le puede
llamar mucho más la atención una escena
muy impactante de manera que lo que no
quiere netflix es encerrar los
contenidos en una única categoría ni con
una única apariencia
lo que está haciendo constantemente es
jugar con la ubicación del contenido con
distintas categorías y jugar también con
la presentación de los contenidos
y con el tiempo te conoce también que
sabe cómo te lo tiene que presentar para
convencerte y lo reproduzcas porque si
os ha puesto los pelos de punta cuanto
saben de los contenidos esperada que os
cuente todo lo que saben de vosotros por
que netflix
tiene dos ventajas una que estás viendo
contenido con un dispositivo conectado y
eso deja una huella digital increíble
y dos que no somos conscientes de que
nos están monitorizando que sí que sí
que todos diciendo por ahí que veis
documentales de la 2 como si no hubiese
mañana
pero netflix sabe que te viste élite en
dos días aunque flipas tengo el programa
de no
que monitoriza netflix todo el día la
hora y el lugar en el que te conectas el
dispositivo que usas la calidad de tu
señal de internet
la frecuencia y la intensidad de tus
sesiones donde en contraste el contenido
en qué categoría con qué visualización
si reproduce esa velocidad normal si
pausas si abandonas si le pones un me
gusta uno me gusta
somos la gallina de los huevos de oro
para netflix pensando bien cada hora que
pasamos conectados a netflix estamos
trazando un gigantesco mapa con nuestros
patrones de consumo
le estamos diciendo que nos gusta
de hecho netflix ha conseguido ya aislar
más de dos mil comunidades basándose en
sus preferencias audiovisuales y no
somos tan especiales como creemos lo
normal es con un usuario medio
pertenezca una milla de tres o cuatro de
estas comunidades de gustos y que
netflix recomiende en función de ellas
cuáles son las consecuencias pues
pensando bien esto está afectando a la
manera y al tipo de contenido que nos
ofrece porque no es quién va a comprar
contenido que según todo esté big data
crea que le va a gustar a sus usuarios
pero aparte también netflix produce
contenidos a medida
reflex ya convertido experto en una cosa
en hacer programas que nos recuerdan a
otros programas
pensando bien son programas que
despiertan en ti una sensación familiar
nostalgia emociones y nosotros claro
picamos pero nosotros somos pues como
caroline en poltergeist nosotros vamos
hacia la luz
y de verdad que no me malinterpretéis
decir a mí me encanta ver contenido en
netflix es una pasada
me encanta el poder que me da netflix
pero parafraseando al tío de peter
parker con todo gran poder viene una
gran responsabilidad yo creo que como
mínimo deberíamos ser conscientes de
cuáles son las consecuencias de un
sistema que está diseñado para ponerte
adelante únicamente aquello que te gusta
porque hombre a quien no le va a molar
que le cuelguen toda la temporada de tu
serie favorita de golpe el vince
watching mola cuentos prácticamente
watching en la sala
creo que solamente
claro que nos gusta que nos den pegarnos
un atracón de series pero está
demostrado que afecta a nuestra química
cerebral cuando nosotros nos pegamos un
atracón de series nuestro cerebro genera
grandes cantidades de dopamina verzeri
es adictivo porque es placentero porque
la dopamina funciona como una señal
química que te genera una sensación de
placer como una recompensa natural que
te
impulsa a seguir viendo cada vez más
pero problema es que luego hace que te
sientas miserable cuando terminas la
serie verdad que se sepa que se ha
diagnosticado un caso de adicción a
netflix en el mundo y probablemente no
será el único y aparte en el freezer es
muy cómodo comodísimo
porque te da una zona en la que no
tienes que pensar y tú como tu cerebro
está saturado del día a día
sientes cómodo es fácil es sencillo pero
también pensad que tomar decisiones es
como un músculo se atrofia si no lo
ejercitas
desde aquí yo creo que es importante que
seamos conscientes de que más que nunca
hoy en día necesitamos desengaños
necesitamos malas experiencias
necesitamos contrarrestar todo este
ecosistema digital que lo que está
haciendo es afianzarnos en ideologías en
modas en opiniones en gustos porque al
final el contenido que te incomoda el
contenido que te desafía el contenido
que te hace pensar es el único que te va
a hacer salir de tu letargo y que
despiertes
[Aplausos]